des fils qui n'en finissent pas depuis
hier aux heures de pointe ça bouchonne à
tour en cause deux axes d'entrée de la
ville fermés pour travaux une sortie de
la rocade ouest et le rond-point
Saint-Sauveur avec des répercussions
jusqu'à l'avenue de Grammont ce mardi
les automobilistes tentent de s'adapter
on a pris un peu d'avance on est parti
un peu avant pour gérer le truc donc ça
va pour partir en voyage prendre avant
parce que du coup on prend une
demi-heure on prend les 5 minutes mais
bon en partant plutôt ça ira ça va on se
dit on connaît des raccourcis on attend
paisiblement au rond-point Saint-Sauveur
les travaux ne font que commencer la
circulation y est fermée jusqu'au 26
août des itinéraires de déviation sont
proposés sauf qu'ils sont eux-mêmes très
vite engorgés pas le choix répond la
municipalité qui incite chacun à
privilégier les mobilités douces si les
gens peuvent prendre le vélo plutôt que
la voiture qu'il le fasse effectivement
on peut prendre le rond-point
aujourd'hui à pied ou à vélo ce sont des
travaux qui ont un impact et c'est pour
ça qu'on les fait pendant la période le
festival pour essayer de minimiser cet
impact la situation devrait toutefois
s'améliorer rapidement avec la
réouverture de la sortie porte de la
riche sur la rocade ouest